مشاهدينا تشهد الاروقه الدبلوماسيه خصوصا
ضمن الناتو محاولات لايجاد صيغه مقبوله
لتقديم ضمانات الامنيه لقياف بصرف النظر
عن السيناريوهات التي ستخلص اليها حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا سبقها ان قدم عدد من
الدبلوماسيين والخبراء العسكريين تقييمهم
لما هو ممكن الامن العام السابق للنيتو
اندرياس اقترح تسليحه اوكرانيا بشكل جيد
وترتيب شراكه استراتيجيه على اساس ثنائيا
مع الغرب بما يسمح بنشر جنود في اوكرانيا
اما قائد القوات الامريكيه السابق في
اوروبا الجنرال بن هاجسس فيرى ان الضمانات
الامنيه لن تكون كافيه دون عضويه كامله
لاوكرانيا يضمنو وتزويدها باسلحه بعيده
المدى لرد» اما السفير الايطالي السابق
لدى النيتوس ستيفانو ستيفاني سيارات ان
فكره الضمانات الامنيه برمتها قد عفا
عليها الزمن
ان الحل يكمن في مسماه حلولا دبلوماسيه
ابداعيه تضمن توفير بعض الاحتمالات القويه
للسلام والامن